ah j'ai apporté les copill
attends c'est goen mais à distribué
alors il su il su tout de suite parce
qu'ils vont tous feuilleter alors on
fera ça on fera ça en fin de
cours non on peut faire ça assez vite
alors juste est-ce que vous êtes
contente déjà parce que j'aimerais qu'on
fasse un petit bilan c'est goen parce
que je suis je suis très heureux de vous
voir est-ce que vous êtes heureuse de
venir nous voir tous les jeudi ou pas
très heureuse frement j'ai beaucoup de
retour en plus vous regrettez pas très
bien en plus vous avez vu Mo même dans
la rue je suis arrêté on a tout compris
sur le prix de l'essence depuis qu'on
vous avez écouté c'était mon père
c'était mon père c'était mon
père même sur les suj grave quo sur le
harcèlement là a un bon débat c'est
vivant on s'est amélioré aussi ma mère
vous adore ah non mais je vous jure ah
c'est bon elle vous adore vous voulez
que je vous dise la véritéer un jour non
mais je vous le dis bah je dis tout
ouais ben elle avait pas voté pour vous
en 2007 et ben elle a regretté là ah ben
voilà elle m'a dit bah tu vois
Colen elle se représente là et ben je
vote pour ces
Goolen c'est vrai je ne rigole
pas ma mère elle en plus elle avait
toujours voté à gauche avant ouais et là
elle elle elle avait un grand amour pour
Nicolas Sarkozi ah c'est pour ça voilà
elle elle a eu un flash voilà donc voilà
et et et là vous avez vu le résultat
maintenant et maintenant elle a un très
grand amour pour vous je vous jure elle
me dit c'est Golen arrête pas de me dire
est-ce que c'est Golen c'est Golen j'ai
dit bah je peux pas lui demander on
verra en 2027 mais elle me dit si c'est
la la candidate qu'on attend toutes
qu'on attend tous la candidate de gauche
qu'on attend tous qu'on attend tous un
candidat gauche qui qui rassemble tout
le monde voilà exactement républicain
elle me dit ben si c'est s Goolen et ben
tu peux lui dire déjà elle a une
voix c'est un bon début la voix de ton
père qui veut pas divorcer donc il qui
votera comme
moi donc de voix déjà déjà il y en a
deux déjà y a déjà il y a tout le monde
ici obligatoire sinon je lesvire non
mais je te dis je lesvire c'est
obligatoire attendez oh on est c'est
c'est la famille déjà déjà et le public
je pense qu'il y en a pas mal aussi donc
déjà on est bien voilà c'estonen
maintenant on va pouvoir parler du Cléa
parce que ça va être dans le program
faut-il qu'on soit vivant c'estd que la
planète reste habitable exctement vous
disz ça pour
Daniel non non elle vtera pour vous vous
savez même si pied sous terre allez le
climat c'est explique alors le climat
alors voilà qu'est-ce que le
réchauffement climatique d'abord on va
en entendre beaucoup parler d'abord on
entend parler dans l'actualité avec les
dégâts les inondations les les ouragans
vous avez vu qu'un ouragan vient de
frapper quand même les pays tempérés
c'estàd nous ou avant c'était
inimaginable par rglement climati non
voilà on va pas
Jeon climati et on va beaucoup en parler
aussi parce que dans moins d'un mois il
va y avoir la grande conférence mondiale
sur le climat qui a lieu tous les ans
qu'on appelle les COP
confér par et ça vient de voilà ça a
toujours été appelé comme ça et euh donc
il y a plein plein de choses à vous
expliquer sur le climat moi j'ai présidé
donc la COP en 2016 au moment présidé
des trucs au moment où elle a été mise
en application donc c'est vrai du coup
j'ai plein de choses à vous raconter ce
que j'ai choisi de faire aujourd'hui
c'est de vous expliquer comment pourquoi
il y a du réchauffement climatique et
deuxièmement de prendre l'exemple de la
fonte des glaciers et qu'est-ce que ça
provoque la la fonte des glaciers ouis
ouis puis après si c'est intéressant
dans si vous avez des questions bien
entendu alors j'ai on aura des petites
questions à poser on aura des petites
questions alors question ici pour les
élèves quelle différence y a-t-il entre
le climat et la météo vous levez bien le
doigt très bonne question très bonne
question vousê vous êtes encore en
classe
[Musique]
vous quelle différence vous faites entre
le climat et la météo alors je dirais
que la météo c'est un peu dans l'immédat
et le climat c'est à longue échéance oui
c'est un peu ça c'est c'est pas mal oui
la même chose mieux mais la moi j'ai la
météo correspond à des fluctuations à
court terme tandis que le
climat non mais regardez-moi ça non mais
regardez-moi C accoutrement madame
royalch donc alors donc le climat
effectivement la météo on peut la
prédire à 5 jours le climat on regarde
la
tendance que donne cette évolution du
climat fait des moyennes et donc on peut
voir on peut comparer les saisons par
rapport aux saisons précédentes on peut
regarder ce qui se passe sur une année
on peut regarder ce qui se passe sur 10
ans on peut regarder ce qui se passe sur
un siècle et aujourd'hui l'année qui
vient de s'écouler a été la plus chaude
depuis le début du siècle pour toute la
planète et donc ça a des conséquences
dramatiques en terme de dérèglement
climatique effectivement on peut
distribuer ça pour que j'ex on va
distribuer ça
il y a pas un délégé cl délégé cl on
peut
distribuer écoutez une are
écoutezadame question écoutez bien parce
que souvent entendre parler et en fait
si vous maîtrisez pas c'est une question
de démocratie ça aussi hein c'est c'est
ce travail que je enfin cet échange que
j'ai avec vous c'est faire comprendre à
tout le monde ce qui se passe parce que
les concepts les mots sont parfois
compliqués et les réalités méritent
d'être expliqué et sont souv d'ailleurs
assez simple c'est vous maîtresse avec
les
CL c'est pour vous montrer que j'étais
allé dans l'épaule et que je savais de
quoi je
parlaissop
dissip allez s'il vous plaît écoutez
bien écoutez bien
aussi la météo quand vous sortez et qui
fait un degré de plus vous le sentez pas
ou 1 degr et demi plus 2 degr vous ne le
sentez pas à l'échelle de la planète 1
degr degr de plus c'est une catastrophe
c'est-à-dire que ça modifie
considérablement les équilibres naturels
ça provoque bah des tyfond des
inondations des sécheresses de la
désertification et cetera toutes les
catastrophes climatiques et donc nous
avons décidé ce qui a été décidé à la
conférence de Paris sur le climat dans
l'accord de Paris c'est que d'ici la fin
du siècle le climat ne devait pas se
réchauffer de plus de 1 der et demi ça
paraît petit 1 deg et dem et pourtant
c'est considérable à l'échelle de la
planète et pour donc regardez le premier
graphique qu'on peut projeter également
comment fonctionne le réchauffement
climatique pourquoi il y a du
réchauffement climatique donc vous voyez
la flèche jaune c'est le soleil qui
arrive sur la terre c'est le soleil et
cette couche bleue qui est autour de de
la de la terre là c'est l'effet de serre
ça marche comme comme si une serre voyez
c'est quand il a une vitre ou un
plastique et la chaleur rentre et cette
couche de d'effet de serre qui est de
au-dessus de la c'est les gaz à effet de
serre qui se sont compilés là dans cette
couche comme s'il y avait une cloche sur
la terre vient de la pollution par par
quoi gazaz quel gaz qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces
gazes ser alors c'est très simple c'est
quoi les gaz à effet de ser voyez qui
provoquent ça par la pollution le
méthane des animaux de délevage oui ça
c'est secondaire mais c'est surtout le
pétrole le gaz le charbon ce qu'on
appelle les énergies fossiles pourquoi
on appelle les énergies fossiles des
fossiles pares sont dans la terre elles
sont dans la terre elles sont en dessous
elles sont issues de la décomposition
pendant des siècles et des siècles
notamment des des matériaux végétaux et
qu'est-ce que vous connaissez comme
énergie propre par rapport aux énergies
dites fossile qui elle pollue et
provoque regardez cet effet de ser
l'éolienneoli mal hydraulique
hydraulique oui solaire le solaire exa
il aussi la géothermie nucléaire bah
mais non mais non non mais le nucléaire
ne produit pas de gaz à effet de serreah
bravo alors il y a des déchets
nucléaires pas c'est pas une énergie
propre PROE mais ça ne produit pas de
gaz à effet de serre et puis vous avez
la méthanisation c'est la transformation
des déchets en en gaz alors regardez ce
qui se passe pourquoi il y a du
réchauffement c'est que les rayons du
soleil arrivent et normalement ils
retournent vers l'atmosphère mais plus
la la couche à effet de ser plus les gaz
à effet de serre se sont concentrés plus
cette pollution s'est concentré et pu BL
voyez les rayons du soleil reviennent
vers la terre ah ouais et donc comme ils
ne peuvent plus repartir dans
l'atmosphère ils revienne vers la terre
et donc il provoque un réchauffement de
la planète et l'une des principales
conséquences de ce réchauffement de la
planète que vous avez sur le graphique
suivant j'ai choisi donc je vous ai mis
la carte des deux pôles le Pôle Nord ça
s'appelle comment sans regarder ah
Nord le Pôle Sud ès intéressant
l'article est l'Antarctique
l'Antarctique c'est une terre entourée
de mer ah oui l'Arctique c'est le
contraire c'est une mer entouré de terre
voyez c'est très intéressant mais que ce
soit l'Arctique ou l'Antarctique il y a
la fonte des glaces et qu'est-ce que ça
provoque la fonte des glaces à cause du
réchauffement climatique monée des e la
montée des eaux queles eau les EAU les
eocé la montée des EAU ensuite du fait
de la montée des EAU bah le grignotage
des terres le GR ce qu'on appelle
l'érosion de r avec les maisons qui
tombent l'érosion qui tombent les
maisons qui tombent dans l'eau l'érosion
des côtes et pourquoi est-ce que lorsque
les glaces les glaces font la mer
augmente plus vite que la fonte des
glaces pourquoi parce qu'avec le
réchauffement climatique non seulement
il y a plus d'eau dans l'océan mais en
plus avec la chaleur l'océan se dilate
se dilate voilà comme un comme un souffl
comme un gâteau
cuit donc il se dilate et donc c'est
pour ça que ça va très très vite et donc
aujourd'hui et moi je me souviens de de
c'était très émouvant d'ailleurs au
début de la conférence de Paris sur le
climat parce que les chefs d'État les
premiers qui ont pris la parole sont
ceux qui étaient les chefs d'État des
des des pays insulaires des îles ils ont
dit mais pour nous pour nous
dépêchez-vous de lutter contre la
pollution parce que nous c'est une
question de vie de mort nous nos pays
sont en train de disparaître et il faut
que vous sachiez que certains pays ont
même acheté des terres sur les
continents pour pouvoir déplacer leur
population quand leur pays va
disparaître c'est ça qu'il faut
absolument bien comprendre et l'autre
élément qui est quand même très très
très curieux et très étonnant c'est que
l'épaule se réchauffe deux fois plus
vite que le reste de la planète on
pourrait dire on pourrait penser il fait
froid ça se réchauffe deux fois plus
vite c'estàd que quand nous allons
augmenter de 1 et demi ou de 2 degrés
j'espère qu'on réussira à être en
dessous l'paule c'est 3 degrés de plus 4
degr plus et parfois 7 degr de plus au
pôle parce qu'ils sont près du soleil
parce qu'ils sont le boulang même si ça
dépend à quelle à quelle période mais
surtout comme dit le le grand savant
jean-loutien jeoutien exactement les
pôle de vert les pôles de blanc
deviennent verts ça veut dire que quand
la glace fond les rayand du soleil qui
sur le blanc se réfléchissaent vers
l'atmosphère donc quand les rayons
dardent sur les pôles il ils imprègnent
la terre et donc ils fondent ils font
fondre la glace y compris la la terre
gelée et c'est ça qui provoque
l'accélération de la fond des neiges
savez-vous de combien le le Mont Blanc
le Mont Blanc le la crème la crème la
crè il a fondu il a fondu il faisit 4807
4809 combien il a fondu en 2 ans non
mais non dis pas de
bêtis 2 ans chef il faisait 4809 m
maintenant il en fait combien je crois
ex braà donc 2 cm 2
m 2,22 cm 2 m,22 cm en 2 ans c'est
considérable pour ceux qui connaissent
cette région à pleurer parce qu'on voit
la glace recule et donc en effet la
glaceont va va dans la mer faut savoir
aussi que les glaciers c'est les
réserves futures d'eau
potable là aussi du coup le cycle de la
de la nature est profondément perturbé
dites-moi euh l'artile n'est-il pas en
passe de devenir le nouvel
eldorado ça a été dit aussi en effet
ouis pourquoi c'est le nouvel
eldoradotien qui a dit ça non ou parce
que comme la glace fond vous voyez les
ressources du sous-sol par exemple au
Groenland où je suis allé les ressources
du sous-sol qui était inatteignable
avant à cause la couche de glace très
épaisse aujourd'hui on peut aller
chercher les les ressources de de à
refuser l'exploitation oui mais enfin il
y a du coup il y a une compétition
économique par quand vous voyez quand
vous voyez les pays qui sont autour de
l'Arctique voyez le Canada l'Alaska
l'Europe du Nord bien évidemment la
Russie bien évidemment donc il y a une
compétition économique et l'autre
l'autre chose étonnante c'est que à
force de de de la fonte des glaces
autrefois quand on pouvait pas circuler
en Arctique il fallait avoir des des
routes beaucoup plus importantes
maintenant on peut maintenant on peut
avec des bateaux souvent polluants
l'Artique est entré qui était un
territoire vierge l'Artique
etantarctique sont rentrés dans une dans
une logique de de pollution qui est très
inquiétante et puis surtout aussi ce
qu'on appelle les les peuples
autochtones donc ce qu'on appelle autrre
fois les Esquimaux mais les inuitïes
c'est-à-dire en Arctique il y a des des
peuples qui habitent cette région du du
monde qui sont profondément déstabilisé
et puis tout ce qu'on appelle la
biodiversité c'est-à-dire tous les
animaux dernière photo que je vous ai
mis c'est la photo des ours qui sont qui
sont en voie de de de disparition mus
détresse finalement par la des Glac ils
peuvent plus regarder ils peuvent plus
pêcher ils peuvent plus déer et vous
savez vous savez ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que les êtres vivants
nous les humains c'est nous qui avons
détruit la planète par les activités
économiques et parce qu'on a pas le
courage de lutter plus vite et plus fort
contre contre les pollutions ça va être
un enjeu hein au mois de décembre pour
savoir si il va y avoir un sursaut pour
rester la d'ici la fin de ce siècle en
dessous des 1 degr demi de réchauffement
ce qui voudrait dire écoute bien que on
est capable de de réduire de 40 %
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles 40 %
moins d'avion 40 % de moins de voitures
qui polluent 40 % de moins de gaspillage
d'énergie dans les bâtiments et cetera
mais il y a des solutions c'est ça qui
est positif il y a des solutions si il y
a une dynamique volontaire et si on est
capable de lutter contre les lobes qui
veulent se croiser les bras puis se dire
bah non demain c'est pas nous demain peu
importe les générations futures c'est
pas la peine de se donner du mal et
cetera voyz alors que voiture électrique
en France elle a été inventée il y a 25
ans je vous rendez compte et aujourd'hui
il y a toujours pas de réseau partout de
recharge de de véhicules électrique et
les prix sont encore beaucoup trop chers
parce que le lobby de l'industrie
automobile par le pétrole a résisté
résisté résisté alors que c'est les
Français qui ont inventé la voiture
électrique c'est les Chinois qui vont
mettre sur le marché la première voiture
c'estou bon marché alors que voilà moi
je me souviens être all en conseil des
ministres en voiture électrique fabriqué
en France tout le monde s'est fiché de
moi bah oui c'est
bien sûr tout le monde a ricané et bien
aujourd'hui il avait que les Chinois qui
sont venus visiter l'usine deè dans les
de ils vont mettre sur le marché donc
voyez il faut à la fois de l'imagination
de la créativité de la volonté et puis
que tout le monde comprenne bien les
enjeux pour que tout le monde est envie
d'agir sans que ça soit transformé en
punition en impôt en contrainte et
Cera exactement alors qu'il a des
solution pour économiser l'énergie non
c'est bon voilà merci alors c'esten
merci et j'adore votre petite photo ah
oui magnifique ah oui franchement non
mais il a CEN mais c'est passionnant
d'aller dans les dans vous avez été dans
lespaule oua ple de qui
avec cétait au
Grenland vraiment une belle femme
incroyable de plus en plus belle je dire
de plus en plus belle maesse mais je
voulais vous le dire vraiment je vous
jure tous mes copains vont voter pour
vous
également bon alors est-ce que vous avez
une question une question allez des
petites questions alors oui
oui d'accord Madame Royale absolument on
est tous concernés mais est-ce qu'on
peut faire ça sans la Chine sans la
Russie sans les États-Unis c'est pour ça
que tous les pays sont là conférence
climat mais ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
c'est que les États-Unis vivent comme
s'il y avait quatre planètes voilà
l'Europe comme s'il y avait trois
planètes la Chine comme s'il y avait
deux planètes et les pays pauvres comme
l'Afrique les pays les plus pauvres
c'est en plus ceux qui subissent le plus
le réchauffement climatique alors que
nous nous avons suré notre développement
grâce au pétrole et maintenant on leur
dire bah non n'utilisez pas de pétrole
nous bien enfin vous avez pollué la
planète et nous on n pas accès au
développement parce que onait pas accès
au technologies de l'énergie solaire
donc tous les pays chauds devrai avoir
accès aux technologies de l'énergie
solaire on doit avoir des panneaux
solaires partout dans les pays chauds
voyez donc les enjeux ils sont ils sont
considérables et
donc c'est ça aussi c'est que le
réchauffement climatique crée des
inégalités Nord sudud creuse des
inégalité nord- sudud écoutez-moi bien
pour terminer puis qu'il va y avoir un
débat sur l'immigration ouis
moi je ne sais plus mais il y a un débat
qui a commencé sur l'immigration si on
ne résout pas la question du
réchauffement climatique réfug clim
voyez l'migration de la lesmigration de
la misère notamment sud sud les gens qui
fuitent les déserts qui fuitient la
désertification l'effondrement des
identités agricoles de proximité à cause
de la désertification et à cause de la
déforestation si on donne aux pays les
plus pauvres l'accès à l'énergie pour
pouvoir conserver l'alimentation pour
pouvoir conserver le poisson qui est
pêché en faisant des des lieux
frigorifiques qui qu' n'y a pas il faut
savoir que c'est dans les pays pauvres
qu'il y a le plus de pertes alimentaires
faute de moyens de conservation de
l'alimentation donc l'accès à l'énergie
c'est pour ça qu'on avait créé
l'alliance solaire internationale
notamment pour tous ces pays elle est
crucial pour que les gens puissent vivre
dans leur village dans leur pays avec
leur agriculture sinon ben ils prendront
la mer pour pour trouver de meilleures
conditions donc vous voyez l'enjeu du du
climat c'est aussi un enjeu de
ai et de justice climtique on peut le
garder ça c'esten c'est cadeau merci
merci
beaucoup
ch les chér allez on va continuer